Time to debate Lincoln.
Oy.
You didn’t like Lincoln?
I liked it about as much as you can like a
2 and a half hour history lesson, sure.
(laughs)
You know those film strips they used to show
us back in high school?
It was about as entertaining as one of those.
That’s a huge overstatement, and you know
it.
Is it?
Yes it is.
Is this or is it not, at the end of the day,
a movie that’s about the passing of a piece
of legislation?
It is.
Might as well be an episode of The West Wing,
circa 1865, only with even less snappy banter.
That’s a good joke, but it’s not remotely
accurate, and you know it.
(THAT WAS EASY).
Do you ever get tired of losing to me in these
debates?
I get tired of you scoring points without
actual debate, but I can do it too.
Daniel Day Lewis was awesome in this movie,
and there can be no argument.
(THAT WAS EASY)
Liam Neeson would have been better.
What?
What did you say?
Nothing.
Alright, my turn.
The speechifying.
The what?
You know how I knew Daniel Day Lewis was going
to win the Oscar for this movie?
Because every other scene in this movie is
a speech, soliloquy, or big storytelling moment
for Lincoln.
The only scenes in the movie that aren’t
big Lincoln speeches are the scenes where
he’s walking from place to place in between
two big Lincoln speeches.
I think Lincoln himself was prone to giving
speeches and stories…
I don’t care if it’s all he ever did in
his old-timey life, it doesn’t make for
good cinema.
They should have called it Best Actor: The
Movie.
( THAT WAS EASY)
Now, I’m gonna argue this with you becausetThe
speechifying was what made it good, you can’t
just go scoring points whenever you want to.
You know when I’m allowed to score points
for something like that?
Now, now now!
(THAT WAS EASY)
You’re a dick.
Not as big a dick as Lincoln was to his son,
and that’s my next point.
How can a movie that celebrates a cold, distant,
emotionally abusive father like this as a
hero be a good movie?
(THAT WAS EASY)
It worked for Star Wars.
Another problem… no suspense.
No suspense?
You’ve gotta be kidding me.
There’s no suspense in this movie.
From the first few minutes I knew that they
were going to get the legislation passed.
That’s because it happened in real life!!
Exactly.
Bad writing.
Way too predictable.
Do you feel the same way about Apollo 13 then?
Well was Apollo 13 real?!
Yes.
I’m taking a point either way.
(THAT WAS EASY) And I’m also taking a point
for the ending, okay, where they cop out and
show his death.
You can’t do a Lincoln movie without showing
his death.
Then f*cking show it!
Don’t flash forward, allude to it, then
flash back to another d*mn speech.
Alright?
Have the balls to show it if you’re gonna
show it.
But you just spent the last two and a half
hours telling me this movie was about the
legislation and not the assassination, alright,
so then have the balls to end it without copping
out and going to the assassination.
I think maybe you--
(THAT WAS EASY) I’m also taking a point
because Lincoln’s dirty.
Lincoln is dirty?
He’s dirty man.
He hires those lobbyists to bribe, intimidate,
coerce, and he basically buys the vote.
So this movie’s conclusion is that dirty
politics is okay, as long as you’re right.
And that doesn’t work because every f*cking
politician thinks they’re right, and they
can’t all be right.
(THAT WAS EASY)
If you think politicians are pure at all then
you probably think the Earth is flat.
Of course I do, don’t be an idiot.
The Earth is round, dumbass.
That’s what I said.
Shut up.
I know what I said.